miserable Umfragewerte sinkende
Mitgliederzahlen und ein Dauerstreit mit
Sarah Wagenknecht seit 12 Monaten
versucht Martin Schirdewahn als
Parteivorsitzender der Linken die
Probleme seiner Partei in den Griff zu
bekommen doch momentan steht sie
schwächer und zerrissener Daten je wie
er aus der Existenzkrise rauskommen will
und warum auch linke Partei Mitglieder
mit der AFD kooperiert haben darüber
rede ich heute mit ihm hier im
thüringischen Apolda herzlich willkommen
zum ZDF sommerinterview
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum ZDF
sommerinterview vielen Dank wir treffen
uns hier in Apolda und zwar das gehört
zu ihrem Wahlkreis wir sind an einem
besonderen Ort nämlich vor dem
eiermannbau Bauhaus Fans wird das
bekannt sein das war der Architekt
nachdem das hier benannt worden ist aber
das Gebäude hat noch eine andere
Geschichte hier sind nämlich lange Zeit
in der DDR Feuerlöscher hergestellt
worden und da gibt's für mich eine
inneren Zusammenhang mit sie sind linken
Parteivorsitzender in ihrer Partei Brenz
an allen Ecken deswegen erste Frage wie
war das erste Jahr als Feuer löschen da
Parteivorsitzender ach naja ich habe die
Partei ja jetzt Vorsitzender in einer
Situation übernommen wurde tatsächlich
einige Krisen in der Partei vorher
herrschten und ich finde dafür haben wir
uns eigentlich ganz gut geschlagen als
Partei insgesamt wir haben ein paar sehr
wichtige Dinge auf den Weg gebracht zum
Beispiel die Erneuerung begonnen das
heißt programmatisch auch strategisch
wir denken darüber nach wie wir neue
Mitglieder gewinnen können wir uns
organisatorisch und strukturell
weiterentwickeln und das eingebettet
auch in sehr konkrete inhaltliche
Vorschläge zum Beispiel einen Plan für
ein gerechtes Land oder auch ein
Ostdeutschland planen und ich glaube wir
haben da sehr gute Akzente gesetzt
klingt nach einer langen Liste das ist
der Blick nach innen wenn sie den Blick
nach außen richten hier in Thüringen war
sozusagen ihre letzte Version hier
regiert noch ein Linker
Ministerpräsident aber Sie müssen gerade
hier auch dabei zuschauen wie die AFD
Ihnen den Rang abläuft wann ist das
eigentlich passiert und wie ist das
passiert dass sie sich ausgerechnet hier
im linken Kernland den Kontakt zu den
Wählern verloren haben ja den haben wir
ja nicht verloren also Bodo Ramelow das
haben sie ja gesagt als
Ministerpräsident hier wir sind hier die
stärkste seit der Bundestagswahl in
Umfragen im Moment ist die AFD ziemlich
gut aufgestellt aber ich bin mir
ziemlich sicher dass die Thüringerinnen
und Thüringer im nächsten Jahr bei der
Landtagswahl eine Wahl zu treffen haben
und zwar auf der einen Seite zwischen
einem Ministerpräsidenten der seit
Jahrzehnten an ihrer Seite kämpft
ungefähr vor 30 Jahren genau auf den Tag
gab es in Zella-Mehlis eine riesen
Demonstration in Thüringen wo die Leute
um den Erhalt ihrer Arbeitsplätze
gekämpft haben
das war der Höhepunkt der arbeitskämpfer
auch im bischoferode das ist kollektives
Gedächtnis und Bodo Ramelow war schon
dabei und die WählerInnen und WLAN
Thüringen werden sich zu entscheiden
haben zwischen einem Ministerpräsidenten
der ihre Interessen vertritt der die
Demokratie verteidigt und einem
Faschisten werden da ist viel Spezialist
thüringisches dabei die Thüringer werden
das verstehen sie haben aber auch noch
viele andere Aufgaben vor sich in der
Linken darüber wollen wir jetzt sprechen
dafür jetzt hoch aufs Dach bitteschön
[Musik]
wir hatten es gerade schon angesprochen
die AFD ist erfolgreich auch hier in
Thüringen auch da wo sie als Linke lange
Zeit erfolgreich gewesen sind das muss
für sie bitter sein hier im Osten wo sie
mal sozusagen die ostvolkspartei gewesen
sind dabei zuzuschauen was hat die AFD
aus ihrer Sicht was sie nicht haben nein
was ich gerade vollzieht ist meiner
Ansicht nach ein Aufstand der
abgehängten Bevölkerung der abgehängten
Regionen insbesondere hier im Osten als
hier am dramatischsten ist gegen die
Politik der Bundesregierung in Berlin
und man muss auch tatsächlich sagen wenn
man sich das ansieht und alle Umfragen
ergeben dass er auch die Unzufriedenheit
mit der Bundesregierung in Berlin ist
enorm 70% der Menschen hier in der
Gegend sagen es geht überhaupt gar nicht
was die da abliefern und die Leute
fühlen sich einfach im Stich gelassen
und ich finde das ist die fatale
Wahrheit an dieser Stelle auch die
Bundespolitik die Regierung unter Merkel
aber auch jetzt unter Scholz haben den
Osten einfach vergessen jetzt ähm sagen
sie da ist die Unzufriedenheit mit der
Bundesregierung groß aber die Folgefrage
für Sie als Parteichef müsste ja sein
warum kommen die Leute dann nicht zu
ihnen als unzufrieden also nochmal die
Frage was bietet die AFD da was sie
nicht bieten naja für uns war
tatsächlich als Partei ziemlich
schwierig und herausfordernd die
corona-pandemie wir sind eine Partei die
auf den Straßen auf den Plätzen sein
muss die im direkten Gespräch sein muss
wir sind ja heute hier in Apolda ich war
vor kurzem mit einem Nachbarschaftsfest
hier und wir haben die Leute aus der
Stadt eingeladen und dann kamen sie auch
vorbei am gegessen getrunken die Kinder
haben gespielt dann haben wir irgendwie
Skat geklappt und da kann man ins
Gespräch und stellt die Fragen wo drückt
euch eigentlich das schon da reicht es
vom Marktplatz von der Bank die dafür
bis zur Weltpolitik und diese Art der
Verbundenheit müssen wir wieder
herstellen als Partei und wir haben da
tatsächlich durch die corona-pandemie
gelitten und andererseits und das muss
man auch selbstkritisch betrachten haben
wir im Vereinigungsprozess zwischen
damals PDS und wer es geht auch das
Augenmerk stärker auch auf den Aufbau
West gelegt das war richtig das ist auch
immer noch richtig aber wir müssen uns
jetzt wieder stärker auf den Osten
fokussieren tun das auch und Gregor Gisi
und ich habe mir am Anfang dieser Woche
einfach auch ein Plan für ein gerechtes
Land vorgeschlagen wo wir unter anderem
eine Lohn Offensive Ost fordern zu den
Sorgen der Menschen kommen wir nachher
nochmal die sie haben gerade eben gesagt
dass sie wie sich wieder Bemühen um den
Kontakt zu den Leuten
es gibt aber ja tatsächlich vor Ort in
den Kommunen mittlerweile schon viele
Orte an denen die AFD eine entscheidende
Rolle spielt und bis zur vergangenen
Woche hat man über die Frage wie man
damit umgehen soll in den anderen
Parteien eigentlich nur hinter
vorgehaltener Hand gesprochen dann kam
Friedrich Merz und hat unter anderem
auch Sie persönlich ziemlich auf die
Palme gebracht Daniel erinnern uns noch
mal daran den 60 Sekunden wie das war
der Furor war groß als Friedrich Merzig
vergangenen Sonntag äußerte zum Umgang
mit der AFD natürlich muss in den
Kommunalparlamenten dann auch nach Wegen
gesucht werden wie man gemeinsam die
Stadt das Land den Landkreis gestaltet
Entrüstung darüber allen halben auch bei
der Linken das gleichzeitig von
Friedrich Merz die Brandmauer
eingerissen wird gegenüber der AFD und
damit der extremen Rechten und damit den
verhindern der Demokratie der Weg
gegeben wird das halte ich wirklich für
fatal das spielt auch keine Rolle ob das
erstmal nur auf kommunaler Ebene
passieren soll so pauschal sieht ein Ex
Grande ist gerade nicht was für Martin
sagt das völlig richtig für die
Bundesebene
interessanter ist die Kommunalebene aber
da gab es immer schon Formen der
Zusammenarbeit so geschehen bei allen im
Bundestag vertretenen Parteien in Waren
an der Müritz etwa stimmte die Linke
schon 2020 einem afd-antrag zu wie das
mit dem uneingeschränkten moralischen
Anspruch des Parteichefs zusammenpasst
unklar es ist Schmunzeln waren sie haben
sich da sehr deutlich ausgedrückt den
Feinden der Demokratie ebnet man da den
Weg haben sie da am Montag als sie das
gesagt haben schon gewusst dass auch bei
ihnen in der Linken manche Leute mit der
AFD zusammenarbeiten es gab einmal einen
Fall soweit ich weiß der ist ja erwähnt
worden und da gab es dann auch einen
entsprechendes Ausschlussverfahren an
dieser Stelle also wir ziehen das schon
eine ganz klare Brandmauer aber was ich
erlebe und das ist da muss ich einhaken
es gab nicht nur einen Fall also wenn
sie nur den kennen dann muss ich sagen
es gab auch andere ein weiteres Beispiel
ist von 2022 im Juni da waren sie gerade
schon Parteivorsitzender da ist in
Neubrandenburg ein AFD Mann zum Vorsitz
des Kulturausschusses gewählt worden
auch mit linken stimmen da ist also auch
längst Praxis was sie an der
Parteispitze ausschließen sprecht
spricht die Parteispitze da nicht mit
der Basis oder hören die einfach da muss
ich sie korrigieren Frau energy die hat
der Landesverband auch reagiert und das
ist auch in Brandenburg Meisterwerk na
gut wenn einzelne sozusagen in einer
Situation so reagieren aber die Partei
dann trotzdem geschlossen zeigt dass das
nicht geht dann ist das auch richtig
dann ist doch klar dass die
parteiposition das es gibt für uns keine
Zusammenarbeit mit der AFD die AFD ist
eine antidemokratische
menschenfeindliche Partei und nicht
umsonst wird in der Gesellschaft jetzt
auch intensiver immer wieder darüber
diskutiert welche Wege man findet um den
Aufstieg der AFD und der ist fatal für
den gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt
aufzuhalten wir haben als Linke darauf
reagiert mit unter anderem den Plan für
ein gerechtes Land wo wir nicht nur eine
lohnen Offensive Ost fordern sondern
auch die Anhebung des Mindestlohnes
gesetzlichen Mindestlohn auf 14 Euro wir
sind hier im Osten und ein Drittel der
ostdeutschen arbeitet unter
prekärstenbedingungen für den mindesten
weil das das treibt mich wirklich auf
die Palme dass die Bundesregierung dann
zustimmt dass der Mindestlohn ab dem 1
Januar 24 auf nur zwölf Euro 41
angekommen wird das sind drei Euro man
muss doch kein Mathematik Genie sein um
zu erkennen dass im letzten Jahr die
Inflation 8% gestiegen ist und in diesem
Jahr bislang um sechs dass die
Lebensmittel immer teuer werden die
Mieten und die Energie also die Leute
werden
sie weichen jetzt der Frage nach ihrer
eigenen Partei aus sie haben gesagt wenn
man von oben klar macht dass es nicht
geht dann ist das schon in Ordnung was
ich jetzt mal grob zusammen aber es
klappt doch da eine riesen Lücke
zwischen dem orangenen Anspruch den Sie
als Partei Spitze aufmachen und der
Wirklichkeit an der Basis wo die Leute
damit umgehen müssen mit der mit der
Situation dann muss es Gregor Gysi hat
den haben wir eben gehört der sagt ja
schon das passiert doch längst auf
kommunaler Ebene da gibt's also auch
eine Dunkelziffer schauen sie da bewusst
weg oder machen Sie sich einfach nicht
ehrlich ich habe doch gerade gesagt dass
die Landesverbände dann jeweils reagiert
haben bei den Fällen die uns be geworden
sind und wer natürlich
eine klare brandmauernde die Fälle
werden uns ja dann auch bekannt gemacht
logischerweise ich weiß dass in
Neubrandenburg der Landesverband
reagiert hat also der
mecklenburg-vorpommersche
landesverbandregierung ich weiß das in
Brandenburg der Landesverband reagiert
hat und da wird eine klare Grenze
gezogen und es ist auch wichtig dass man
der AFD gegenüber eine klare Grenze
zieht das ist nicht hinnehmen war dass
die mit ihrer Politik tatsächlich immer
weiter die Gesellschaft gegeneinander
Stellen auseinandertreiben aber das
beste Mittel gegen den Aufstieg der AFD
ist ein gerechtes Land ist eine bessere
Politik und dafür stehen wir als Link
und dafür streiten mir und das was
Friedrich Merz gemacht hat nämlich die
Tür zu öffnen für die Demokratie Freunde
und gleichzeitig deren Themen
aufzugreifen immer wieder den
Kulturkampf zu verstärken das ist
absolut fatal weil damit wird den
einfach der Weg weiter geebnet und auch
dass die Bundesregierung auf
europäischer Ebene und damit meine ich
SPD grün und FDP da surrechtsreform
zugestimmt haben und da mit dem Druck
der rechten nachgegeben haben macht
deutlich in die weit diese
Regierung aber auch die konservative
Opposition kein Mittel dagegen haben und
ich sage noch mal das beste Mittel gegen
den Aufstieg der AFD ist eine gelingende
Sozialpolitik sie benennen jetzt die
Probleme aber Konsequenzen muss ich noch
einmal ergänzen zu den fallen die wir
genannt haben gab es jetzt nicht
wirklich wir haben nur einen einzigen
Fall gefunden in dem es einen
Parteiausschluss bei ihnen gegeben hat
aber sie haben schon angesprochen sie
wollen wieder stärker werden tatsächlich
mit eigenen Themen sie haben ja auch
schon einige genannt das ist das
Hauptproblem gerade bei ihnen in der
Partei die Frage wie wird die Linke
wieder stärker und da zerreißt es sie ja
praktisch also auch da gibt es große
Flügelkämpfe im Mittelpunkt steht oft
Sarah Wagenknecht die will Wähler
zurückholen die früher mal links gewählt
haben und es geht ja nach eigener
Aussage vor allem umarme und Armut
gefährdete Menschen hören wir mal kurz
rein welchen Grund sie dafür nennt ein
Großteil dieser Menschen sieht bei
keiner Partei mehr eine
Interessenvertretung und wenn überhaupt
bei einer und das ist die Tragödie dann
ist es die AFD das ist die
Tragödie sagt Sahra Wagenknecht hat sie
damit Recht
naja wie gesagt das herrscht meiner
Ansicht nach gerade ein Aufstand gegen
die Politik der Bundesregierung und das
ist tatsächlich
linke natürlich ist das eine Tragödie
muss man ja nicht drüber diskutieren an
dieser Stelle dass dieses Land nach
rechts zu kippen droht wie viele andere
europäische Länder ist natürlich eine
Tragödie und natürlich muss eine
sozialistische moderne
gerechtigkeitspartei die meine darauf
ihre eigenen Antworten geben aber dass
die Bundesregierung sich seit Monaten in
der Öffentlichkeit darüber streitet wie
eine Kindergrundsicherung zu finanzieren
sei oder ich erwähne noch mal dass der
Mindestlohn noch 12,41 angehoben wird
oder dass die Lohnentwicklung weit
hinter der Inflation zurück bleibt dass
die Altersarmut steigt das ist
ernährungsarmut in einem so reichen Land
gibt das ist doch eine Respektlosigkeit
dieser Bundesregierung gegenüber den
Menschen in diesem Land und da muss man
doch einfach auch sehen dass wenn diese
Respektlosigkeit anhält und wenn nicht
sozusagen aus der Krise heraus diese
Bundesregierung endlich die Kraft findet
eine gelingende Sozialpolitik zu leisten
dass dann die Leute von der Stange gehen
und dagegen stehen wir als LINKE und das
machen wir sowohl in dem Kulturkampf wo
wir eine klare Brandmauer gegen rechts
ziehen gegen die AFD als auch mit
unserer starken und deutlichen
Sozialpolitik an der Seite der
Arbeitnehmenden Bevölkerung und auch
derjenigen die von Armut betroffen sind
auch gerne mal auf die innerparteilichen
Verhältnisse gucken denn sie suchen nach
einem Rezept wie sie diese Themen an den
Mann und an die Frau bringen können auch
Sarah Wagenknecht tut das ist treiben
sie ja die Inhalte genauso um wie sie
bei ihr sieht man allerdings die kann
damit Massen erreichen es gab eine
Umfrage Sarah Wagenknecht denkt darüber
nach einer eigene Partei zu gründen und
eine Insel Umfrage hat ergeben dass
diese Partei hier in Thüringen aus dem
Stand aus 25% käme stärkste Partei
werden würde und der AFD 10% wegnehmen
würde von den Stimmen können Sie sich in
dieser schweren Existenzkrise in der die
Linke sich gerade befindet leisten
dieses Potenzial liegen zu lassen
auch so Frau Wagenknecht das in der
Partei auch relativ umstritten ist da
gibt es viele Wagenknecht Fans Amira
Mohammed Ali ihr Fraktionschefin im
Bundestag sagt zum Beispiel also so wie
das jetzt läuft so können wir in der
Linken nicht miteinander umgehen und
Gregor Gysi hat auch gesagt ich will
nicht das Sarah die Partei verletzt
verlässt und wenn man an die Basis
schaut da sieht man auch die
Begeisterung für die Abgrenzung zu Sahra
Wagenknecht ist nicht groß im Gegenteil
wir können uns das mal anschauen neulich
gab es live im Netz eine Veranstaltung
der Linken hieß die Linke wieder stark
machen schauen Sie mal was die Leute da
gesagt haben die Spaltung geht ja viel
tiefer die geht ja durch die ganze
Partei an der Basis und ich wenn man
jetzt sag mal Sarah jetzt nicht als
absolute Böse erklärt hat man schon
Probleme in dieser Partei und ich finde
jetzt muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen mit
dem Beschluss von Parteivorstand war
Sarah nicht die spalterin danke schön
ich möchte die Frage stellen
ist es Sarah die die Partei spaltet oder
sind es nicht wir die die Partei
gespalten wir haben so eine kluge
intelligente engagierte Frau mit Sarah
Wagenknecht und wir müssen uns die
kämpfen wir müssen uns bei ihr
entschuldigen
ja das sind heftige Emotionen ich frage
jetzt nicht nach der Entschuldigung aber
wenn sie sich diese Leute angucken wie
stehen ja Pass vor toto brauchen Sie
diese Menschen in der Linken nicht mehr
doch natürlich brauchen wir diese
Menschen nicht Kämpfe und die gesamte
Partei kämpft um alle Mitglieder und wir
kämpfen nicht nur um diejenigen die in
der Partei sind sondern auch darum neue
Mitglieder zu gewinnen wir öffnen die
Partei auch wieder in die Gesellschaft
unter anderem durch die Listener die
Listen Vorschläge für die Europawahl wo
wir mit Gerhard Trabert und auch Carola
Rakete zwei sehr renommierte bekannte
Persönlichkeiten gewonnen wir kämpfen
natürlich um jedes Mitglied und dass man
inhaltliche Unterschiede miteinander in
dieser Partei diskutiert das ist doch
selbstverständlich und ich bin der
allerletzte der sich einer Diskussion
nicht stell ganz im Gegenteil ich fahre
auch viel durch das Land und treffe mich
mit genossen und Genossen meiner Partei
und diskutiere über den Zustand dieser
Partei und da treffe ich im übrigen auch
auf sehr sehr viel Zustimmung dazu dass
man eine rote Linie zeichnet und
aufzeigt die bedeutet wir können über
alles intern reden aber intern wir
können alle Konflikte intern lösen aber
eine Neugründung aus dieser Partei
heraus das ist tabu und das trägt im
übrigen die Partei auch mit die
Aufstellung zur Europawahl haben sie
gerade schon erwähnt dass es ganz
interessant wenn man darauf schaut sie
haben Carola Rakete als prominenteste im
Kopf dort aufgestellt die ist bekannt
geworden als Aktivistin zum Thema
Flüchtlinge jetzt vertritt sie für die
Linke andere Schwerpunkte ich darf das
mal zitieren sie sagte bei ihrer
Vorstellung die Klimakrise ist die
größte gerechtigkeitskrise der Welt und
in der Ukraine muss die Perspektive der
Betroffenen im Zentrum stehen Klimakrise
und Ukraine Krieg das spricht eine junge
urbane Schicht an und junge urbane Teile
ihrer Partei aber wäre es nicht ihre
Aufgabe als Parteivorsitzender ein
Programm und auch Konzepte vorzulegen wo
alle mitgehen können auch die
schimpfenden Parteimitglieder die wir
eben gehört haben ja aber das machen wir
doch das machen wir doch indem wir zum
Beispiel erwähnen ist noch mal einen
Plan für ein gerechtes Land oder einen
Plan für Ostdeutschland aufzeigen wo
insgesamt die soziale Frage im Zentrum
steht ich selbst habe in Europa
Parlament
überall mit großen digitalunternehmen
angelegt und auseinandergesetzt deren
Steuer Gebaren deren
steuervermeidungsstrategien aufgedeckt
und auch darum gekämpft dass dieser
Markt der einigen wenigen oligopolen
Strukturen gehört und Unternehmen gehört
aufgebrochen wird der kämpfen gegen die
Mächtigen und Reichen gegen die großen
Konzerne und wer Europa will so sagen
wir der muss es ihnen nehmen und da
unterbreiten wir ein Angebot zudem auch
Gerhard Trabert gehört der ein
renommierter armenarzt ist der
bundesweit Bekanntheit gewonnen hat
durch sein soziales Engagement unter
anderem möchte auch kandidieren
alledem ihre die eine Gewerkschafterin
ist ich werde kandidieren Carola Rakete
und damit decken wir doch die gesamte
Bandbreite des fortschrittlichen
Gesellschaft und das ist gut und wenn
man sich dafür gibt es aber noch Kritik
wenn ich das zum Schluss noch einmal
einwerfen darf die Bremer
Wirtschaftssenatorin der Linken hat
schon gesagt das ist eine grünisierung
der Partei und eine zweite Grüne Partei
die brauchen wir nicht
das ist eine Kritik die sitzt oder naja
das ist keine Vergrößerung wenn wir über
eine gerechte Besteuerung großer
Unternehmen reden wenn wir darüber reden
wie Armut bekämpft werden kann und die
Arbeitnehmerin Rechte gestärkt werden
können dann heißt es nicht dass die
Partei grüner als die Grünen wird
sondern ganz im Gegenteil wir sind
natürlich in unserer Klimaschutzpolitik
radikaler als die Grünen weil wir das
auch als eine antikapitalistische
Politik begreifen weil wir sehen dass
insbesondere die Superreiche mit ihrem
Lebensstil die Umwelt so verschmutzen
das aber dann am Ende die armen dafür
zahlen sondern wenn man sich jetzt noch
mal überlegt wie z.B Klimaschutzpolitik
dieser Bundesregierung aussieht in dem
habe ich ein heizungsgesetz vorliegt bei
dem die soziale Frage komplett außen
vorgelassen wird und ausgeklammert wird
dann ist doch selbstverständlich dass
die Leute hier auf die Barrikaden gehen
weil in meinem Wahlkreisbüro sitzen die
Leute und heulen weil sie nicht wissen
wie sie diese Politik ertragen sollen
und sich leisten sollen können und da
sind wir als LINKE gefragt und von daher
das tun wir auch und wir kämpfen
natürlich mit allen fortschrittlichen
Kräften in dieser Gesellschaft zusammen
und dazu gehört nun mal auch unter
anderem die Bewegung dazu gehören die
Gewerkschaften und Leute die sich mit
Armut auseinandersetzen
die wir heute für dieses Gespräch hatte
sie kämpfen und man wird dann sehen bei
wem das tatsächlich ankommt herzlichen
Dank für dieses Gespräch an dieser
Stelle ich bedanke mich
das war unser sommerinterview mit dem
ko-vorsitzenden der Linken in der
nächsten Woche geht es weiter dann
treffe ich Tino krupala den kofo
sitzenden der AFD ihnen herzlichen Dank
fürs zuschauen und einen schönen Abend
[Musik]